juin 2009 228 victimes périssent dans le
crash du vol Paris Rio le procès de
cette catastrophe aérienne s'est ouvert
le 1er octobre dernier 8 semaines
d'audience ou Airbus et Air France était
jugé pour homicide involontaire mercredi
le parquet a estimé qu'aucun manquement
ne pouvait être attribué aux deux
entreprises et qu'il ne requerait aucune
condamnation du côté des parties civils
c'est donc les pharements et les la
Turquie étalaient la rencontre de Claire
Durousseau cette tourangelle a perdu sa
nièce et le mari de cette dernière dans
le drame
de nouveau patienter encore quatre mois
avant le jugement rendu par le tribunal
de Paris on espère que le 17 avril à
13h30 on apprendra une bonne nouvelle
donc ça va être long on va y penser tous
les jours on va attendre et attendre et
encore attendre mais vous savez en
attendu 13 ans alors on est plus à 4
mois près
gardez espoir de pouvoir enfin tourner
la page en 2023 avec ce verdict final
sur la responsabilité ou non d'Airbus et
d'Air France lors de ce vol Rio Paris